vegetarier essen meinem essen das essen
weg das ist so ziemlich der dümmste
spruch zum fleisch 40 den es gibt aber
er hält sich hartnäckig genau wie das
tiere essen
das hält sich auch hartnäckig denn die
mehrheit der deutschen verzichtet eben
nicht auf fleischkonsum sondern ist
davon ziemlich viel jedes jahr aber es
ist nicht alles denn es ist nicht nur so
dass wir viel fleisch essen wir essen
doch nur ganz besonderes fleisch und vom
tier landet ganz schön viel dann
eigentlich da wo es nicht hingehört
nämlich zum beispiel auf dem müll
und wir sprechen heute am
weltvegetariertag darüber ob man das
nicht anders machen kann also erst mal
muss man überhaupt tiere essen und wenn
man meint die ersten zu müssen was die
meisten von uns ja wohl denken kann man
die nicht anders essen geht das nicht
irgendwie anders und mein
gesprächspartner heute der ist kein
vegetarier der ist auch kein veganer
ganz im gegenteil der lebt beruflich
davon dass er tiere verwurstet zerhackt
berät kocht dünstet serviert und dann
läuten auf den teller auf den tisch
bringt aber der macht das anders als
andere
nina niebergall zeigt uns mal wie er das
macht bei christoph hauser steht fleisch
auf der speisekarte und dann auch noch
die teile von tieren die nicht unbedingt
nach jedermanns geschmack sind doch
dahinter steckt eine philosophie ein
schwein ist mehr als nur ein schnitzel
zu legen dass wir nachhaltig gulasch
gleich ein system in dieser lage
ok normalerweise werden gerade mal etwa
50 prozent eines tieres zu lebensmitteln
verarbeitet der rest landet in
tierfutter kosmetik oder müll hier wird
das ganze tier verarbeitet der name des
restaurants ist programm nichts
weggeschmissen von herz niere landet
alles auf dem teller eine botschaft auch
an die gäste
ich nicht so das ist ja wieder und
christoph hauser ist bei mir in berlin
steht vor seinem fleisch kühlschrank
heißt das so christoph ist unser 13
okay das was das hängt denn da gerade
bei dir so rum also jetzt rechts im
schrank in vilsheim rücken aus der
schorfheide von unserem jeweiligen und
auf der anderen seite haben wir
einladung gemacht von einem mantel
schwein das mit 30 prozent mandeln
trester gefüttert worden ist weil dieses
rücken versalzung getrocknet das ist und
lade ich wollte mich gerade als genau
wohin stehen haben also sein
es ist quasi vom vom schweinerücken das
fett das wird gesalzen getrocknet im
besten fall noch geräuchert und dann
kann man das nach dem trocknen ganz dünn
aufschneiden und zum beispiel zu
geflügel servieren oder ein wild
geflügel bereich ist es ganz toll wenn
wir das einfach leicht verschmerzen
lässt okay das klingt schon sehr lecker
muss ich zugeben er sät ich bin kein
vegetarier und kein veganer aber
christoph wir haben sie gerade gesehen
ihr macht das anders in eurem restaurant
als andere ihr versucht das ganze tier
zu verwerten wie seid ihr denn auf diese
idee gekommen
naja mein geschäftspartner michael und
ich haben in der sternegastronomie und
auch in einer anderen mine gearbeitet in
deutschland da wurde relativ viel
weggeschmissen weil es einfach keinen
platz gefunden hat auf dem teller bei
dem gast und weil der gast auch nicht
bereit war irgendwie 50 euro für ein
menü zu bezahlen und irgendwie das ende
von fisch zu sehen auf dem teller an wir
wollten das anders machen wir wollten
ganz klar überraschungsmenü servieren
ganze tiere einkaufen wissen woher sie
kommen wissen wie sie aufgewachsen sind
und die menü zu servieren mit oder ohne
innereien und auch zum beispiel in
vegetarischen bereich sind wir im menü
aufgebaut
wenn wir diese nicht nur die sinnlos
hotel philosophie verfolgen sondern auch
diese lief gut geschichte was uns am
herzen liegt
gemüse zu präsentieren das heißt lief
zurück heisst ihr verwertet alles an der
pflanze vom platz was ich wahrscheinlich
beim kochen auch wegschmeißen würde bis
hin zur wurzel genau vom blatt bis
wurzel wird alles zu verarbeiten und auf
dem teller zu präsentieren damit dass
der gast auch wirklich auch als blätter
ist oder auch als wurzeln ist aber warum
habt ihr dann nicht gleich gesagt dass
mit dem fleisch lassen wir seien berlin
ist ja sowieso vegetarische veganer
hauptstadt europas gefühlt wir machen
komplett nur vegetarisch ist es so dass
in berlin und auch ich glaube
deutschland wird immer mehr leute auch
die vegetarische alternative wählen ist
sehen wir bilden auch im restaurant also
bestimmt 40 prozent unserer gäste ersten
vegetarisch bei uns haben wir wollten
nicht auf fleisch verzichten weil wir
den gästen zeigen wollen wenn man
fleisch ist da ein gutes fleisch und das
bekommt er bei uns sind das ist unsere
politische botschaft an unsere gäste in
der start und das kommt sehr gut an
also wir wollen nicht auf fleisch
verzichten wir müssen's reduzieren ganz
klar aber nicht darauf verzichten um die
erzeuger um berlin herum in brandenburg
zu unterstützen aber warum denn nicht
verzichten das ist ja so der der kern
der veganen und der vegetarischen
bewegung zu sagen wir müssen keine tiere
töten
das sind lebewesen wie wir auch die
spüren schmerz die haben angst die haben
freunde die freuen sich wenn sie ihre
mutter sehen diese lebewesen können wir
einfach leben lassen und für essen halt
wurzeln beeren und was sonst noch so in
der erde wächst das ist auf jeden fall
ein gutes argument das ist ihre
lebewesen sind die sollten leben sie
sollten alt werden können ich bin da
völlig auf der gleichen seite also ich
finde es super wir verarbeiten die alte
mutterkühe die 16 jahre alt sind oder
wir verkaufen nur schweine die
mindestens ein jahr alt sind oder wenn
nicht sogar manchmal zwei jahre alt wir
wollen auch dass die tiere gut gehalten
werden mit guten gutem futter gefüttert
worden sind nicht mit soja zugefüttert
zugefüttert werden also alle diese
punkte unterstützen wir und wollen wir
auch machen und wollen wir auch tun wir
auch bei uns im restaurant
nichtsdestotrotz oder dennoch sage ich
fleischgenuss ist ja auch um mehr gäste
davon zu überzeugen weniger fleisch zu
essen und dann gut ist deswegen muss es
uns doch geben
das ist meine meinung es gibt menschen
die sind da ganz anderer meinung zum
beispiel hilal sezgin die ist
journalistin autorin tier rechnerin und
die sagt zum fleischkonsum folgendes ich
denke dass man tiere eigentlich
überhaupt nicht schlachten sollte auch
nicht schlachten darf moralisch wenn man
nicht jetzt extrem not leidet oder in
früheren zeiten und orten wo man sich
nicht anders ernähren kann tiere hängen
an ihrem leben genau wie wir und wie
christ diese leben extrem ab nur weil
wir nun mal bock haben jetzt genau das
und nicht etwas anderes zu essen und
diese sorte von bock oder appetit oder
lust oder gewohnheit die ja eigentlich
nur durch macht legitimiert wird ist
moralische hab ich in ordnung da
christus ist dir und deinen kunden dein
gestern restaurant die moral völlig egal
solange sie gut schmeckt also ich hab
dann ganz gutes beispiel werden unsere
mutterkuh die claudi die war 16 jahre
alt wir haben ja bewussten namen gegeben
im restaurant zu servieren und haben die
dann auch so erklärt am tisch bei
verschiedenen gästen ein paar gäste
haben dann gesagt wir essen jetzt nicht
die klaro diversen heute die
vegetarische alternative ich glaube den
bewussten umgang mit fleisch muss an
oberster stelle stehen also ich selbst
es sind zwei drei mal die woche
vielleicht fleisch ansonsten lerne ich
mich auch vegetarisch oder von fisch und
ich glaube aber für eine gesunde für
einen gesunden körper
muss alles so ein bisschen im prinzip
wie so eine säule funktionieren also wir
sollten ein bisschen fleisch essen viel
vegetarisch viel gemüse viel getreide
viel obst und dann noch fisch dazu ich
glaube dass das gesamtvolumen ist
einfach für den körper braucht er
einfach von allem etwas und davon bin
ich überzeugt da würden die veganer und
ich habe hier zum beispiel in der
redaktion hinter mir eine sitzen würden
sagen mir brauchst du nicht kannst du
auch alles mit erbsen zum beispiel
ausgleichen oder mit ganz vielen müssen
also fleisch essen muss nicht sein um
gesund zu ernähren
ja das ist ja man muss tatsächlich sagen
dass das nicht also ich bin jetzt ein
bisschen natürlich gibt es ersatzstoffe
oder auch jetzt wie wie den mystischen
angesprochen worden sind oder erbsen
oder kichererbsen zum beispiel pilze das
sind ganz wichtige elementare
grundbausteine für eine vegetarische
küche die wir auch einbauen kann
ich glaube aber man kann jetzt nicht
sagen
man sieht jetzt den schuh aus oder sind
fleisch so aus und wir hätten jetzt kein
fleisch mehr sondern alles nur noch im
gemüsebereich oder im vegetarischen und
veganen bereich ich glaube das ist auch
nicht funktioniert dass wir alle jetzt
nur noch vegetarisch oder mit getreide
uns ernähren
weil es einfach auch diese anbauflächen
auch nicht geben würde
ich bin absolut gegen massentierhaltung
ich bin auch gegen zufütterung mit soja
ich weiß dass das klima stehen auf uns
zukommen er und die natürlich auch durch
diese massentierhaltung entstehen oder
werden jetzt immer schlimmer und wir
müssen drastisch unseren fleischkonsum
reduzieren
es ist mir bewusst und das ist auch
unseren gästen wirst und das ist auch
thema wenn es jeden abend im restaurant
das heißt jeden abend hat die diskussion
wir gucken mal hin die diskussion bei
uns zum beispiel youtube oder klaus
schreibt ich bin seit zwei jahren vegan
seitdem ich das mache habe ich kein
problem mehr mit diabetes und fühle mich
seitdem sehr wohl meint was benötigt man
denn vom tier das ist mal eine
interessante frage was benötigt man vom
tier und wir haben auch gefragt wird die
innereien essen da würde mich mal
interessieren
gab es da bei dir tatsächlich so eine
hemmschwelle das erste mal hirn zu essen
oder augen zu verwerten oder ich weiß
nicht was noch in so einem tier das drin
ist roden rinder roten habe ich gelesen
schmecken total toll ist so dass wir uns
den innereien angenommen haben
wir servieren wir uns keine augen und
weist so war zum beispiel wenn ich das
persönlich nicht mag ich habe es
probiert alles was bei uns da wird wird
im inneren bereich mag ich und das kann
ich das kann ich auch vertreten und
dahinter stehen und auch im restaurant
stehen und dass dann servieren die
thematik die wir haben ist ja wenn ein
tier geschlachtet wird dann sollen wir
ihn halt den respekt wenn wir die
innereien mit verarbeiten und man darf
nicht vergessen dass unglaublich viele
schlachtabfälle anfallen sich so
genannten schlachtabfälle sind die
innereien finde ich die neuen edel teile
eines tieres man sieht ja dieses hotel
bewegung
das wird uns auch irgendwann
also werden immer mehr menschen und ich
glaube wenn wir ein komplettes tier
essen wenn wir dann tiere essen dann
kriegen wir auch mehr menschen sagt ich
glaube das problem ist dass wir
jahrelang oder die letzten 30 40 jahre
einfach viel zu rücken und viel gegessen
haben und uns gar nicht mehr bewusst war
was noch im tier drin ist und auch ein
tier steckt und da wurde zum beispiel
keule und schulter und braucht es wurde
nie im restaurant präsentiert oder wenig
im restaurant präsentiert sondern kann
in irgendwelche großen geschichten oder
in die kosmetikbranche oder wurde wieder
zum tierfutter wiederverwertet und ich
glaube dieses hotel bewegung die wir in
deutschland haben seit fünf oder sechs
jahren ist das ziel den fleischkonsum
der endverbraucher auch drastisch zu
reduzieren da hast du mir jetzt ein
super stichwort gegeben nämlich wird
essen ziemlich viel fleisch wird
deutschen und eben nicht alles davon
das haben wir jetzt glaube ich ziemlich
deutlich gemacht petra pesel hat man ein
paar zahlen dazu zusammengefasst jeden
tag eine ordentliche fleisch roulade
also 165 gramm fleisch isst jeder
deutsche im durchschnitt täglich macht
60 kilogramm pro jahr zählt man hier
vegetarier nicht mit dann sind es sogar
ganze 67 kilogramm
die nordamerikaner kommen fast an die
100 kilogramm marke heran
würden die deutschen ihr fleisch
ausschließlich zu rouladen verarbeiten
dann würden sie an 219 tagen aus
schweinefleisch zubereitet an 77 tagen
aus geflügel und an 59 aus rind- und
kalbfleisch
so wurden 2017 in deutschland insgesamt
771 millionen schweine geflügel tiere
und rinder geschlachtet
viel viel bedeutet auch viel futter 60
prozent des in deutschland angebauten
getreides landeten tröten
zusätzlich werden große mengen an futter
importiert viehzucht ist auch ein
klimakiller
sie setzt klimaschädliche gase wie
kohlendioxid aber auch methan und
lachgas frei die produktion von einem
kilo rindfleisch verursacht zwischen
sieben und acht und 20 kilo
treibhausgase während obst oder gemüse
bei weniger als einem kilo liegen
insgesamt ist die deutsche
landwirtschaft für 7,3 prozent unserer
treibhausgasemissionen verantwortlich
gut die hälfte davon entsteht durch die
haltung von nutztieren
der fleischkonsum in deutschland ist in
den vergangenen jahren zwar geringer
geworden naturschutzorganisationen
halten aber nur die hälfte für
ökologisch vertretbar
tja tiere essen ja aber nein und wenn ja
wie viele
das diskutiere ich heute mit christoph
hauser der hass koch in einem restaurant
in berlin und dort verwerten sie alles
vom tier wirklich vom los total so heißt
die bewegungen also von der nase bis zum
schwanz christoph wir trinken hier
gerade das ein bisschen den kommentaren
ich versuche mal so ein paar vorzulesen
also noch youtube passt mal auf gibt es
hier
man kann so viel rum reden wie man will
aber letztlich gibt es keinen grund
fleisch zu essen außer der eigenen
egoismus schreibt ti chur darüber kommt
sebastian caspar mit dem argument wir
verbrauchen die weltweit 83 prozent
unserer nutzflächen für die tierhaltung
gewinnen dadurch jedoch nur 18 prozent
der weltweiten kalorien das ist schlicht
völlig ineffizient ich muss dazu sagen
sagen wir es nicht überprüft kann ich
sagen die stimmen aber auf jeden fall
macht es sinn ein tier frisst mehr grün
braucht wie grünzeug und deswegen ist es
natürlich nicht so richtig effizient
ausländer man meint das fleisch essen
nicht dass verwerfliche die
unerträgliche massentierhaltung ist das
unethische und unmoralische und in die
richtung gehen auch ganz viele andere
kommentare die wir haben sodass geht
kommt drauf an wie das tier gehalten
wird christoph bekommt ihr dann eure
tiere her ich habe schon gehört so das
ist von unserem jäger oder das ist die
mutterkuh von und habt ihr im namen
gegeben habt ihr tatsächlich eure ganz
eigenen bezugsquellen und könnt da
hingehen und sagen dass dir nämlich
morgen mit
ja also gefahren
also wir befinden uns eigentlich in zwei
stunden radius um berlin herum
wir haben zum beispiel bearbeiten wir
ganz tollen erzeugerin sie seien mit der
maria mandy von der schwarzen co die hat
black angus rinder mit der arbeiten mal
ganz eng zusammen andere restaurants
bestellen dort irgendwelche fleischteile
und sie versucht es auch an den
endverbrauchern zu formaten einfach
gutes fleisch für faires geld kann man
bei ihr bestellen im online shop genau
so machen wir das mit dem schweine
bereich da sind wir in potsdam zu hause
potsdam grube beim potsdamer saulheim
zwei jungs die sich selbstständig
gemacht haben vor ein paar jahren die
haben 120 tiere 120 schweine frei laufen
das ganze jahr draußen dann offen ist
also eine kleine überdachung für den
winter der von beiden seiten offen ist
wir haben uns erzeuger gesucht die eine
tolle landwirtschaft betreiben und eine
tolle tierhaltung und das photo contest
region das sind irgendwelche trester
abschnitte von muster reihen zum
beispiel im schweine bereich die kriegen
ein bisschen getreide zugefüttert und
ansonsten nur das natürliche wasser
auffüllen unter der obstplantage oder
abfallendes obst oder nüsse
wir versuchen auch den gästen zum
beispiel am abend immer die möglichkeit
zu geben alles was sie bei uns essen
können sie auch kaufen also jetzt nicht
nur bei uns sondern wir geben den
kontakt von den erzeugern wo jeder gast
sagen kann wenn dann kauf ich gutes
fleisch ist total sehen wollen und davon
überzeugt oder das klingt total super
christoph aber auch dazu gibt es leute
oder zumindest unsere gesprächspartnerin
hieß es ging mit einer sehr anderen
meinung habe ich gerade schon mal einmal
eingespielt ein o-ton von ihr
journalisten autoren tierrechtler und
die sagt zu ich sage mal zu dieser
ganzen biofleisch bewegung folgendes
wenn sie sich die buchhaltungs
bestimmung anschauen die sind ein
kleines bisschen ich sage nicht mal
besser ich sage weniger schlecht als die
anderen das ist meistens auch
massentierhaltung nämlich in dem sinne
dass die ganzen natürlichen
verhaltensweisen nicht ansatzweise
ausgelebt werden können dass die kinder
weggenommen bin und natürlich die tiere
sterben auf dieselbe weise das heißt sie
werden gewaltsam getötet bio ist dann
eigentlich nur so ein siegel
unser besseres gewissen damit es uns
weiter essen das wetter es erlaubt hat
sie doch nicht auch in puncto christoph
weil
zum beispiel wenn ich auf dem biolandhof
gehe dann sehe ich auch die kälber sind
in der anderen box als die mutter das
heißt es sind die milchkühe die sind
auch nicht zusammen kuscheln ist da
nicht weil wir halt die mich davon
trinken müssen oder wollen oder meinen
zu wissen und die claudia gegessen habt
in eurem restaurant die hat ja auch
nicht gesagt super mit 16 mache ich
hier' schicht im schacht und lass mich
dann von euch verspeisen oder jetzt gibt
ja unterschiedliche also ich muss noch
mal ganz kurz das aufgreifen also es
geht jetzt nicht um das die tiere
abgeschlachtet werden wie das jetzt
gerade hingestellt wird also ich meine
wir arbeiten mit erzeugung zusammen die
haben ein gehege schluss das heißt er
kommt extra jemand der die auf der weide
schießt so das ist das tier fällt um
wird dann abtransportiert aber die
kanadier sind wir das schaffen die das
dass man muss sagen dass es der
angehenden sowie das schönste an sich
einiges für das tier also jetzt anders
wie durch stress irgendwie verursacht
aus der herde rauszunehmen zum beispiel
die maria mandy zum beispiel fährt jeden
tag die tiere mit dem anhänger von wiese
zu wiese also die sind es gewohnt mit
dem anhänger zu fahren und dann gibt
einmal diesen anhänger dann denen die
tierischen automatisch drauf und so
werden die dann zum schlachthof gefahren
also die tiere haben keine haben kein
stress also ich würde sagen es gibt
wirklich tötung
politik ist kein stress haben und uns
auf das auf das thema bio also ich finde
das bier und der richtlinie ist eine
gute richtlinie wir brauchen so eine
richtlinie für endverbraucher
wir arbeiten mit wenig bio erzeugern
zusammen weil unsere erzeuger einfach
manchmal zu klein sind
die das dann auch nicht haben aber für
mich zum beispiel als gastronom oder
auch als käufer eines tiers ist es
wichtig wo kommt das her was sie
gegessen erkenne ich dann der zeuge kann
ich dem vertrauen wie es der
tötungsvorgang keine langen wege keine
großen transporte das sind doch so diese
wichtigen argumente die man auch hören
kann
soja das genauso hat
die möglichkeit sich gelten christoph
aber ich sage auch mal hier ja natürlich
gegenwind eine pascal schreibt auf
periskop der schönste tod das thema ja
und hier klar die verfechter der
vegetarischen lebensweise auf youtube
zum beispiel wo war das das war s
lendermann schrieben schon das wort
erzeugerin stört nicht tiere werden
nicht erzeugt sie werden geboren die
jedes lebewesen ich mal kurz meine
kollegin daffner nach hinten darf nur
überzeugen nicht die argumente von
christoph hein überzeugen überzeugen
darf nun hinter mir nicht so ich habe
aber schon nachvollziehen können dass
ihr versucht so viel wie möglich es geht
dass es okay ist wie die tiere bei euch
auf dem teller landen das klingt aber
alles wahnsinnig aufwendig das ist ja
also die die massen hat tierhaltung wie
wir sie haben die ist auf streamlining
aus die die muss schnell die muss
effizient sein
das heißt er im endeffekt dass das
fleisch dass ihr produziert das muss man
sich leisten können im endeffekt ist es
dann wieder nur was für die reichen
leute und die menschen die nicht viel
geld haben die können halt weiterhin nur
kohlessen wenn man das so durchziehen
ich glaube dass man das das besagt also
ich sag es unseren gästen immer dann
wenn ein bis zweimal die woche fleisch
ist und ein gutes ein gutes tun zb kauft
egal ob das jetzt hier aus region ist ob
man jetzt wohl raus fährt und sich ein
huhn kauft oder auch eine ente die kann
man aus kochen da gibt es einen taktisch
super einen anderen tag gibt es die
brust man kann sich auch länger länger
ernähren von dem tier also jetzt
geflügel bereiches hat einfach ein
tolles beispiel für zuhause man kann
sich mit dem tier beschäftigen
beziehungsweise mit dem huhn und man
kann irgendwie die brüste als erstes
machen ich sage ich einfach mal
mitreißen wird dann wird eine suppe
gekocht dann gibt es einen tag frei
kassiert am dritten tag gibt zum
beispiel eine hühnerbrühe mit nudeln und
dann muss man nur einmal fleisch kaufen
und man hat einfach länger was davon und
aber das könnte natürlich 25 euro und
nicht wie im supermarkt ja ja natürlich
aber deswegen sind wir doch hier also
deswegen sind doch unglaublich viele
großartige kirche in deutschland mit
tollen kleinen restaurants die die gäste
in die hand
nehmen uns sagen wenn ihr bis 2 oder
wenn wenn ihr fleisch ist dann bitte
doch gutes wenn das ist doch unsere
pionierarbeit so ich bin ja auch gegen
diese massentierhaltung und absolut
dagegen aber das ist doch mein mann muss
doch klein klein betrieben wird uns zum
beispiel auch eine chance geben die welt
ein kleines stückchen zu verändern und
zu verbessern
und wenn wir es geschafft haben wir rund
40 sitzplätze in ihrem restaurant dass
zwei gäste nach hause gehen und mit
einem einsatz nach hause gehen sagen hey
die haben das toll gemacht und wenn dann
gehe ich jetzt wirklich mal zu einem
erzeuger oder zu einem bauern wenn man
nicht erzeuger sagen darf oder zu einem
metzger und koch gutes fleisch und und
nur zweimal die woche und sonst ist die
vegetarisch so und dann haben wir es
doch geschafft
das ist das was wir jeden tag machen
wollte ok ich merke das ist wirklich das
ist eine leidenschaftliche mission
wenn du erstmal auf die
massentierhaltung guckst du hast du
kommst ja aus der gastro du wirst schon
viel gesehen haben was das da so gibt
was würdest du denn sagen wie kann man
das leben der tiere verbessern gibt es
da so dass du sagst schärfere
tierschutzgesetz oder wochen fleisch
teuer oder wir brauchen was weiß ich
vielleicht sogar haben eine maximale
produktionsmenge pro jahr pro
deutschland in deutschland und dann gibt
es halt nicht mehr fleisch und wenn die
im oktober weg ist dann müssen wir alle
ab oktober hat nur noch gemüsebrühe
essen und ich glaube also tatsächlich
dass man das viel mehr regulieren wo es
also man muss den tatsächlich den
biomarkt verstärken die regionalen die
regionalen erzeuger im gemüsebereich und
die bauern zum beispiel im
fleischbereich unterstützen mehr
subventionieren würde ich sagen dass man
einfach kleine erzeuger
unterstützt und stützt und sachen aufruf
quasi an jeden endverbraucher ich meine
wir regulieren doch den den den markt
wenn wenn jeder irgendwie nur noch
sportschuhe kauft die in china
produziert werden
dann stirbt der regionale zu der die
schule produziert natürlich aus und wenn
wir alle gut ist lies kaufen bei uns
gleich um die ecke egal ob wir jetzt in
berlin brandenburg sind oder in bayern
und wenn wir da die einheimischen zeuge
unterstützen ja dann setzen wir doch ein
ganz klares zeichen gegen die grossen
massen tierhaltungsbetriebe die hier
natürlich denken jetzt auch ein aufruf
an die politik ist hier wird er von cara
zum beispiel vorgehalten in welcher
traumwelt lebst du eigentlich wenn 770
millionen tiere getötet werden das ist
schon der trasse zahl ist eine kleine
heile welt nur ein mini kleiner teil
dieses ganzen großen geschäfts so das
heißt im endeffekt ja ja bist du kannst
nicht mal sitzt ist ja genau aber wenn
ich jetzt mein restaurant zu machen
würde dann wären werden 55 menschen die
hier arbeiten und täglich dafür
einstehen erstens wenn sie keinen job
mehr
und zweitens könnten wir die gäste wenn
ich mal versuchen zu überzeugen dass 770
millionen tiere jährlich zu viel ist
also das ist doch meine rede
ja und ich lebe nicht in meiner heilen
welt und ich versuche ein kleines stück
das die welt zu verändern
und ich glaube jeder jeder mensch hat
irgendwie morgens die wahl aufzustehen
und was zu verändern
egal in welche richtung geht oder egal
in welchen job er macht oder geht und
genau so stehe ich jeden morgen auf und
versuche die gäste zu überzeugen
christoph das war ein sehr schönes
schlusswort von dir hier wird noch
munter weiter diskutiert das thema ist
halt weil es sehr nah dran an uns ist an
unserem täglichen leben ziemlich
emotional ich freue mich dass die
diskussion trotzdem einigermaßen
sachlich im netz geblieben ist zwischen
uns ja sowieso christoph ich sag dir
einen schönen guten abend nur dank hat
mich sehr gefreut wird eine zeit der
auch und euch vielen dank für eure
ganzen kommentare fürs zu sehen und
wissen dann was tag um halb neun wieder
damit im nächsten live stream ist bis
dahin noch gut und tschüss
und wenn ihr mehr zum thema
nachhaltigkeit wissen wollt hier gibt es
einen live stream zum thema feindbild
suv oder anderes kontroverses thema
dieser priester ist gegen frauen im
priesteramt und natürlich vergesst nicht
uns zu abonnieren